das ist voraussichtlich die letzte rede
meine letzte rede als
bundestagsabgeordnete weil ich mich nach
23 jahren mitgliedschaft im deutschen
bundestag dazu entschieden habe nicht
erneut anzutreten
deswegen ist ein bisschen wehmut dabei
bei dieser rede
aber ich muss sagen ich bin meiner
fraktion sehr sehr dankbar dass ich
ausgerechnet zu diesem wichtigen thema
meine letzte rede hier im deutschen
bundestag halten war ein thema wo wir
deutlich machen wir durchstoßen erneut
eine gläserne decke die qualifizierte
frauen davon abgehalten hat wodurch sie
abgehalten wurde in führungspositionen
zu kommen und wir verschaffen den
grundsatz dass qualifikation das allein
entscheidende sein muss bei der
besetzung von positionen und nicht eben
das geschlecht diesem grundsatz
verschaffen wir damit weiter durchbruch
meine damen mutter und das hört sich so
einfach an und es hört sich auch so
selbstverständlich an dass die
qualifikation das alles entscheidende
ist aber das war ein hart entschuldigen
sie frau ministerin darf ich bitte um
etwas mehr ruhe und anstand binden danke
und das hört sich so einfach an und so
selbstverständlich aber ich kann ihnen
aus diesen 23 jahren berichten dass das
ein harter kampf war schon in meiner
ersten legislaturperiode in der wand
2001 schon einmal fast davor eine quote
für aufsichtsräte zu beschließen das war
damals noch nicht mal der fall und wir
waren kurz davor gab es ganz viele
stimmen aus der wirtschaft die haben
gesagt das braucht ihr nicht gesetzlich
zu regeln so eine quote brauchen wir
nicht das machen wir ja schon aus
eigenem interesse weil wir die vielen
gut qualifizierten frauen in unseren
unternehmen haben wollen wir haben uns
damals davon überzeugen lassen und
danach ist lange lange lange lange
nichts passiert es hat sich nichts
verändert an der quote in der frauen
entsprechend berücksichtigt wurden
deswegen haben wir im jahr 2015 dann die
quote für aufsichtsräte beschlossen
ein ganz wichtiger schritt und heute
gehen wir eben diesen schritt weiter mit
der quote in vorständen ich sag's ist
ein ganz wichtiges signal an frauen
steht alles offen ihr könnt je
beruf ergreifen euch steht die welt
offen wenn hier entsprechend
qualifiziert zeit nutzt die chance und
das ist ein wichtiges signal dass ich
auch gerne von dieser stelle aus senden
möchte dass alleine das alleine reicht
aber nicht sondern da ist noch viel
arbeit zu leisten dass eben auch die
bezahlung dann stimmt und dass es da
dann nicht wieder hapert und da
unterschiede gemacht werden auch da muss
der grundsatz gelten die qualifikation
und nicht das geschlecht entscheidet da
haben sie für die zukunft noch richtig
viel zu tun da sind wir noch lange nicht
da wo wir eigentlich schon längst sein
sollten dafür wünsche ich ihnen alles
gute viel erfolg und genauso
konstruktive verhandlungen wie ich sie
in diesen 23 jahren erleben durfte
es waren gute verhandlung immer in den
meisten fällen waren sie konstruktiv und
in den meisten fällen ist man auch fair
mit mir umgegangen und ich wiederum
hoffe dass ich ebenfalls fair mit all
denjenigen umgegangen sind die mit ihr
verhandelt haben ich weiß ich kann
manchmal sehr beharrlich sein und auch
immer wieder mit dem gleichen thema
ankommt es nervt vielleicht manchmal
aber es ist auch notwendig denn nur
beharrlichkeit führt zum ziel das kann
man gerade bei diesem thema auch so
sollte ich denn noch jemand einmal auf
den fuß getreten sagt dann bitte ich
dafür um entschuldigung es war nie
persönlich gedacht sondern hatte was
damit zu tun dass sich eben auch für
diese themen brennen
so und jetzt hat die präsidentin pau
vorhin aufgefordert die letzten reden
bei den letzten reden dann nicht als so
viele dankesworte zu verlieren ich sage
danke an alle wird es bei ganz vielen
auch noch persönlich sagen und ich
möchte mich verabschieden mit einem satz
aus einem lied der wunderbaren trude
herr niemals geht man so ganz
bis 10
das und ja da musste ich eben auch
zweimal hinschauen aber natürlich ist
sie ja auch bundesfamilienministerin
seit dem rücktritt von franziska giffey
hat jetzt hier also zum schluss der
legislaturperiode zwei ämter ausgeführt
seit dem 20
leider ist franziska gefahr
zurückgetreten
aufgrund der herzlichen debatte und
arbeite hier auch gestern wurde er das
tor durch fara freien universität berlin
in der debatte geht es jetzt hier weiter
mit marianne ihres hd kühnel für die afg
fraktion sehr geehrte frau
präsidentinnen sehr geehrte damen und
herren die bundestagswahl wirft ihre
schatten voraus in einem der letzten
gesetzesentwürfe dieser
legislaturperiode soll den vorständen
von unternehmen vorgeschrieben werden
wie sie künftig setzt sein müssen es der
vorstand eines börsennotierten
unternehmens mit mehr als drei
mitgliedern besetzt muss mindestens
eines davon eine frau sein
damit greift die coco nicht nur erneut
schamlos in die unternehmerische
freiheit ein sondern ebnet einmal mehr
den weg in richtung sozialismus das
entscheiden werden weil die
qualifikation spielt künftig keine rolle
mehr einzig das geschlecht entscheidet
über die besetzung der
unternehmensführung eine stärkung des
wirtschaftsstandortes deutschland ist
durch solche eingriffe kaum zu erwarten
dass ausgerechnet die union dabei mit
das auch keine überraschung sie bietet
sich damit ihrem zukünftigen
koalitionspartner an
denn schließlich haben sich die grünen
laut wahlprogramm die etablierung einer
feministischen regierung zum ziel
gesetzt zum wiederholten male wird
deutschland deutlich wer schwarz fehlt
der bekommt grün
wer dagegen freiheit statt bevormundung
will der sollte blau wählen meine damen
und herren den freund hatten sind ein
mittel des 20 kreativsten die
grundrechtlich geschützte rentierte
eigentumsfreiheit artikel 14 in die
berufsfreiheit aus artikel 12 sowie die
gleichberechtigung von mann und frau aus
artikel 3 absatz 2 satz 2 grundgesetz
bein namhafte staatsrechtler lehnen sie
daher ab es lässt sich
verfassungsrechtlich einfach nicht
rechtfertigen unternehmen in bereichen
in denen es keine ausreichend
qualifizierten frauen gibt zu
verpflichten und taugliches personal
einzustellen
man sieht die ganze debatte
frauenquote stück des vortages und
widersprüche es ist darauf ausgerichtet
und pflegende rechtsprinzipien die die
vertragsfreiheit und die privatautonomie
zugunsten einer feministischen
planwirtschaft abzuschaffen
denn um nichts anderes handelt es sich
hier wurden regelungen sanktionen bei
nichtbefolgung sind mit den prinzipien
der marktwirtschaft und einer
freiheitlichen gesellschaft nicht zu
vereinbaren eigentlich müsste er hier
auch die fdp auf begehren die sich ja
die unternehmerische freiheit ans revers
geheftet hat aber was sie liebe freiheit
die man demokraten in ihrem antrag
fordern das lässt einen wirklich die
kinnlade herunter fallen sie schlagen
ein verbot für arbeits meetings nach 16
uhr vor sie streben mehr geschlechter
vielfalt in führungsetagen an und sie
fantasieren von diversity als
erfolgsfaktor das anpassung an den
kultur marxistischen zeitgeist
dass man frauen dass man frauen auch
ganz ohne zwang ganz ohne ultra
feminismus ganz ohne journalismus in
führungsetagen bringen kann zeigt
übrigens dass angeblich ach so
reaktionär konservative achso
erzkatholische polen
dort werden mütter und hausfrauen nicht
von einem linken mainstream zu menschen
zweiter klasse degradiert dort wird
nicht durch einen übergriffigen staat
propagiert welche rollen mann und frauen
familie und beruf zu spielen haben das
ergebnis in polen liegt der anteil an
frauen in führungspositionen der 44
prozent im bund diversen deutschland den
gegenüber 28 prozent wenn sie also schon
wirklich viele frauen in
vorstandspositionen bringen wollen dann
nehmen sie sich doch bitte
frauenpolitisch nachhilfeunterricht bei
unseren östlichen nachbarn aber freien
fall
auf keinen fall sollte man wie
vorliegend auf mittel des zwangs setzen
und frauenquoten sind ein solches mittel
frauenquoten produzieren toten frauen
und glauben sie mir keine frau will als
bloße wurden frau abgestempelt werden
wir von der alb ist alles klar
starke frauen brauchen keine toten
vielen dank
[Applaus]
die fdp fraktion ist gegen eine
frauenquote das hat hier ihre opfer im
ausschuss für familie senioren frauen
und jugend noch einmal ausgelegt auf sie
folgt jetzt nadine schön die
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
der unionsfraktion im deutschen
bundestag präsidentin des pulses ein
bisschen hoch für meine größe vielleicht
kann man das nur ein bisschen winter
machen dass wir sehr nett vielen dank
erstmal will ich aus seitens um zwei
fraktionen ministerin lamprecht alles
gute wünschen für ihre zukunft vielen
dank für die zusammenarbeit in den
letzten vier jahren meistens als
justizministerin wo wir ja auch
überschneidungen hatten und dann jetzt
in den letzten wochen auch als
familienministerin nehmen sie die krise
gerne auch mit an franziska gipfel von
der wir uns im hohen haus leider nicht
mehr verabschieden könnten auch hier
konnten auch alles gut wir setzen heute
ein sehr sehr wichtiges gesetz und
deshalb bin ich ein bisschen traurig von
mindesten dass sie nicht noch darauf
bezug genommen haben was wir eigentlich
im parlamentarischen verfahren noch
verändert haben an diesem gesetz wir
haben nämlich ein gutes gesetz noch mal
ein gutes stück besser gemacht
es ist ja leider so dass wenn man
vorstand ist in einem konzern in einem
unternehmen oder in einem start up und
man wird schwanger bekommt ein kind dann
kann man nicht in mutterschutz gehen ist
das unfair
ja denn diese schutzfrist in den ersten
wochen die braucht eben jedes baby und
jede frau und deshalb haben wir das mit
diesem gesetz geändert
und diese änderung geht auf eine
initiative zurück und dort wo wir den er
passte auch heute hier ist und wo sich
viele frauen und männer aus der
wirtschaft dafür eingesetzt haben dass
wir es ermöglichen familienbedingte
auszeiten zu nehmen für den mutterschutz
aber etwa zum beispiel auch für die
pflege von angehörigen
das nutzt frauen wie männern in
konzernen und damit machen wir die
konzerne die unternehmen auch die start
ups familien und damit bringen wir auch
einen kulturellen wandel in den
unternehmen in gange einen kulturellen
wandel den wir auch mit diesem gesetz
mit seinen anderen teilen voranbringen
wollen nämlich mit dem meer der
vorstands quote die wir zum ersten mal
auf den weg bringen und diese
veränderung von oben von der spitze und
gleichzeitig die veränderung von unten
auch durch strukturelle rahmen wird die
man die wir mit der politik schaffen
durch vereinbarkeit bessere
vereinbarkeit von familie und beruf
all das wirkt zusammen und führt dazu
dass mehr frauen in führungspositionen
kommen was kein selbstzweck ist sondern
was dazu führt dass in unternehmen
bessere entscheidungen getroffen werden
das unternehmen erfolgreicher sind
nachweislich und was gerade den jungen
frauen den mädchen auch zeigt man kann
alles werden man kann auf
führungspositionen werden
führungspositionen auch mit familie
vereinbaren auf frauen für große
konzerne gut und erfolgreich bisher noch
zu wenig und das wird sich in zukunft
ändern und dann funkte er uns ganz
wichtig war ist dass wir als stadt mit
gutem beispiel vorangehen und deshalb
bin ich annette widmann mauz so dankbar
dass sie als vorsitzende der
frauen-union den finger in die wunde
gelegt hat beim thema krankenkassen
krankenversichert und
sozialversicherungen
das ist nämlich ein bereich wo es sehr
viele frauen arbeiten der für das leben
für vieler frauen verantwortlich ist wo
aber besonders wenig frauen in den
führungsetagen
sind und wo wir als stadt auch eine
verantwortung haben bei der besetzung
dieser posten und deshalb haben wir auf
ihre initiative hin
diesen punkt in unserer gespräche mit
dem koalitionspartner eingebracht und in
diesem bereich machen wir strengere viel
strengere vorgaben als bei der
wirtschaft hier gelten quoten schon ab
vorstände die zwei oder mehr personen
haben und das finde ich auch richtig da
wo der stadt verantwortung trägt da hat
er eine besondere verantwortung auch für
mehr frauen in führungspositionen zu
sorgen
auch das machen wir mit diesem gesetz
deshalb ein grund hat und gutes gesetz
ich freue mich dass wir es heute
verabschieden können herzliches
dankeschön an alle die daran mitgewirkt
haben herzlichen dank
die fdp fraktion hat ja auch einen
antrag eingereicht da geht es allerdings
eher um die zeit bevor man in das
arbeitsleben startet sie möchte bildung
und wirkt an schulen fordern besonders
in den mint fächern also mathematik
informatik naturwissenschaften und
technik
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte frau ministerin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir leben in
einer immer komplexer werdenden welt
wenn wir diese auch in zukunft
erfolgreich begegnen wollen brauchen wir
unterschiedliche perspektiven und
gemischte teams für die besten lösungen
daher teilen würde ihr ziel mehr frauen
in den führungspositionen in den
vorständen künftig wiederfinden zu
können
auch für uns demokratien ist es auch
klar ein echter nachhaltige und
innovative wandel gelingt nur
miteinander statt einer quote brauchen
wir erst überzeugte freundin meine damen
und herren
unser ansatz ist es ermöglichen er ist
zukunftsfähig berücksichtigt die
unternehmerische freiheit
und interessen meiner generation und die
der folgende wir sind die arbeits und
führungskräfte von morgen also fragen
wir uns doch wie wollen wir in zukunft
leben und arbeiten was tun die
unternehmen im wettbewerb um die besten
köpfe und wie sind die rahmenbedingungen
zu fördern für vielfalt und
vereinbarkeit damit meine ich ganz
konkret beruf und privatleben ganz
allgemein ob hobby ehrenamt oder die
eigene familie sprich kinder oder
pflegebedürftige angehörige und
natürlich wünschen sich dass die männer
genauso wie die frauen und deshalb
wollen die entscheidungsfreiheit in
beide richtungen und für beide frauen
die mit dass dem sollen auch karriere
machen können und männer die führungs
sind sollen zeit für die familie haben
können frauen neben männern nicht zwecke
nein ganz im gegenteil
wie alle profitieren davon meine damen
und herren
und deshalb freue ich mich an der stelle
ganz ganz besonders dass die
familienbedingte auszeiten für
führungskräfte nun im gesetz verankert
werden
das großartige engagement von stay und
dort verena du bist heute unter uns und
unser antrag tragen jetzt früchte wie
viel wie wir gemeinsam erreichen können
liebe bundesregierung das sehen wir wenn
sie gute anträge der opposition in die
tat umsetzen
denn führungskräfte sind haben halt
einfach eine ganz enorme strahlkraft in
eigene unternehmen und zu den
stakeholdern und genau diese vorbilder
diese braucht unser land und zugleich
brauchen wir aber auch die chance der
flexibilität wir brauchen endlich eine
reform des arbeitszeitgesetzes für
mobiles arbeiten aber auch neue modelle
wie job sharing und tabs schirm
wir brauchen talent management und
diversity management in allen
und von anfang an und arbeitgeber und
vorgesetzte die dieses moderne
rollenverständnis in die tat umsetzen
und aktiv fördern
nur damit können wir den kulturwandel
unserer zeit einleiten und erreichen
nachhaltige veränderungen und nein
lieber herr weinbergs liebe union wir
sind noch nicht am ende des kulturlandes
eingereicht haben wir noch nicht er
sondern erst wenn frauen ohne quoten und
männer mit längeren elternzeit bis ganz
nach oben in den führungsetagen
vordringen können und das begrüßen wird
dafür macht sich die fdp die
fortschrittspartei stark vielen dank
vielen dank
auch die linksfraktion hat einen antrag
eingereicht in dem fordert sie dass der
mindest frauenanteil in aufsichtsräten
und unternehmensvorständen entsprechend
ihres anteils an der bevölkerung kotiert
werden soll also mit 50 prozent doris
appel will bespricht jetzt für die
linksfraktionen dass führungspositionen
gesetz von 2015 wird heute erneuert
damit frauen bessere teilweise überhaupt
chancen haben in die vorstände und
aufsichtsräte deutscher unternehmen
zukommen die situation ist teilweise
wirklich mittelalterlich das gesetz ist
entsprechend konsequenter als sein
vorgänger was sein muss und widerspricht
widerspricht falschen glaubenssätzen wie
dem dass es frauen an der nötigen
qualifikation fehlt dass sie sich besser
behaupten müssten oder durch quoten über
vorteile würden vor allem echten
meilenstein allerdings bleibt die
reichweite des gesetzes aus unserer
sicht doch noch ein bisschen zu
bescheiden die privatwirtschaft muss das
führungsposition wirklich überhaupt
nicht fürchten das betrifft bundesweit
ein paar dutzend vorstände nur die jetzt
mindestens eine frau nach besetzen
müssen weil es sonst nicht passiert
das ändert selbstverständlichkeiten
vermeint abbruch aber ein überfälliger
und wir jetzt muss einfach noch mehr
konsequenz gewünscht zum ausgleich von
lohnunterschieden braucht es größere
hebel sicherlich zum vergleich unter den
spitzen verdienenden wo sich der
lohnunterschied zwischen den
geschlechtern besonders niederschlägt
gibt es hierzulande fast 160 tausend
männer und knapp 23.000 frauen nur an
dieser schieflage wird dass
führungspositionen gesetz erst mal sehr
wenig ändern und hier auch hier hätten
wir uns mehr gewünscht
die zielgrößen regelungen von der viel
in den medien zu lesen war wurde
verschärft bislang konnten unternehmen
die in berichten geschlechtergerechte
zielgrößen nachweisen mussten einfach
null angeben frauen nicht vorgesehen
diese haltung läuft so nicht mehr durch
ausnahmen von der regel müssen nun
ernsthafter begründet und offengelegt
werden bei pflichtverletzungen drohen
bußgelder was wir auch richtig finden
aber inwiefern die einhaltung des
gesetzes angemessen überprüft und
sanktioniert wird das blatt noch etwas
zu vage bis heute sind die vorstände
börsennotierter unternehmen zu fast 90
prozent männlichen aufsichtsräten konnte
diese monokultur durch verbindliche 30%
quotierung ein stückweit aufgebrochen
werden nur dort wo fest notiert wird so
ist es einfach gibt es bewegung über
schneckentempo und stillstand hinaus
was du für die vorstände kommt ist
allerdings keine quote sondern eine
mindestbeteiligung allein das wort schon
von einer frau pro vorstand ab drei
personen egal wie groß das gremium ist
eine frau muss zur not reichen und das
kann es nicht sein
auch die sinnvollerweise noch
nachbearbeitete regelung vielen dank
auch von uns vorstandstätigkeiten unter
mutterschutz zu stellen sie hat eine
kehrseite weil väter mit elternzeit
ansprüchen anders behandelt werden und
das allgemein vermittelte
geschlechterbild dann doch eher
traditionell ist insgesamt weiß dieses
gesetz noch nicht ausreichend über die
gleichstellungspolitik dieser
legislaturperiode hinaus die aufgabe
wurde bewältigt aber es braucht noch
stärkere effekte um frauen tatsächlich
gleichzustellen
an seiner wirkung und ausstrahlung muss
noch weiter gearbeitet werden auch wenn
ich mir wirklich vorstellen kann dass
das alles schon reichlich arbeit gemacht
hat und auch das maximum was in dieser
legislatur zu erreichen gewesen ist
vielen dank an dieser tour ist angel
rooney gespräche und gleichstellungs und
queer politik der linksfraktion hat hier
gesprochen auf sie folgt jetzt die
sprecherin für frauenpolitik der grünen
fraktionschefs auch die grünen
beschäftigen sich in ihrem antrag mit
einer quote war anders als die
linksfraktion die 50 prozent fordert
fordert die grünen-fraktion 40 prozent
dank präsidentin meine damen und herren
frau ministerin auch von meiner fraktion
alles gute für sie und ihre zukunft und
danke für die gute zusammenarbeit
kurz vor ende der wahlperiode ringt sich
die koalition dazu durch das
führungspositionen gesetz zwei zur
abstimmung zu bringen das war knapp
dieser gesetzentwurf der hier vorliegt
wurde durch weitere kompromisse nochmals
abgeschwächt dass liebe cdu/csu-fraktion
gleicht einem unterbietungswettbewerb
zur frage wie wenig frauenförderung in
einem gesetz stecken kann
um es klar zu sagen mit der neuen
gesetzesfassung wird in den vorständen
eine echte quote geben sondern nur eine
mindestbeteiligung von einer frau pro
vorstand egal wie groß der vorstand ist
reine männer vorstände bleiben so
weiterhin möglich und auch die
übergangsfristen wurden noch mal
verlängert welches signal wollen sie
damit eigentlich an die vielen frauen im
land senden die endlich gleiche chancen
wollen
es ist höchste zeit für eine
modernisierung unserer wirtschaft wenn
alle talente berücksichtigt werden und
vielfalt in den führungsetagen
abgebildet wird sind die entscheidungen
ausgewogener diversität ist ein gewinn
und stay und bord ist auch einer und
deutschland hinkt um jahrzehnte
hinterher ein echter kulturwandel in
chefetagen ist überfällig
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wenn ich
an die vergangenen monate zurück denke
die lage und nöte der frauen viel zu
spät in den blick genommen wurden
dann lag das auch daran dass in den
entscheidungspositionen noch immer
überwiegend männer sitzen auch hier im
bundestag wer entscheidet ist eben nicht
egal und wir wollen den kulturwandel
jetzt dafür braucht es die kritische
masse von mindestens einem drittel
frauen
das zeigt die forschung sehr klar das
bestätigen auch die erfahrung von
vorstandsfrauen und wir haben in der
vergangenheit leider schon zu häufig
gesehen dass eine frau allein ist nicht
richten kann die männlich geprägte
kultur zu durchbrechen und darum haben
wir grüne einen konkreten eigenen
vorschlag formuliert und fordern in
unserem antrag eine feste quote von
mindestens 33 prozent für alle
börsennotierten und mitbestimmten
unternehmensvorstände die quote soll auf
dem weg zur paritätischen repräsentanz
ab dem jahr 2025 auf 40 prozent
ansteigen und wir grüne wollen dass die
unternehmen verbindliche pläne für alle
auch für die unteren führungsebenen
aufstellen denn faire chancen müssen
alle frauen egal auf welcher stufe der
karriere sie sich befinden bekommen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
abschließend noch ein wort zu den
aufsichtsräten warum sind sie so zaghaft
hier die quote für aufsichtsräte wirkt
und die unternehmen kennen diese quote
und sie haben mit einer ausweitung
gerechnet genau der zahl
und endlich diese ausweitung auf den weg
zu bringen denn bislang ist nur eine
gruppe von rund 100 unternehmen
betroffen
wir wollen den nächsten legislatur eine
auswertung auf mehr unternehmen und
einer erhöhung auf 40 prozent erreichen
der weg für eine moderne
wirtschaftspolitik muss geebnet werden
denn das ist jetzt dran
vielen dank herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
das wort geht ein katja mast von der spd
fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin werte
kolleginnen und kollegen meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren frauen kommen
überall hin
das gilt in der theorie aber nicht in
der praxis und zwar besonders wenn es um
führungspositionen geht
und das obwohl frauen im schnitt bessere
abschlüsse machen als männer an der
qualifikation liegt es also nicht
deshalb liegt es an anderen dingen an
strukturen und netzwerken das nennt man
gläserne decke sieht man nicht gibt es
aber viele sagen frauen bekommen kinder
und es mangelt an der vereinbarkeit von
familie und beruf manche sagen sogar die
frauen sind selbst schuld das ist alles
einfach nur quatsch hauptverantwortlich
sind die strukturen und genau deshalb
ändern wir heute die strukturen per
gesetz zu lange hat die wirtschaft
gesagt das ändern wir selbst es ist
nichts passiert denn sonst wären mehr
als zwölf prozent frauen in vorständen
der dax-unternehmen dass es auch deshalb
fatal weil unternehmen mit frauen in
vorständen wirtschaftlich erfolgreicher
sind als politisch gesteuert werden und
deshalb führen die heute die erste
mindestquoten regelung für die vorstände
in der wirtschaft ein
das ist ein historischer erfolg den wir
künftig ausbauen können und
wieso historisch erstens weil wir
jahrzehnte jahrzehnte dafür gekämpft
haben mit wir meine ich nicht nur frauen
und männer und die vielen fans sondern
auch die vielen verbündeten in politik
wirtschaft und gesellschaft und
natürlich auch meine partei die spd
zweitens weil von einer quote in der
wirtschaft nichts im koalitionsvertrag
steht im wahlprogramm von cdu/csu stand
lediglich dass sie konkret im
öffentlichen dienst etwas ändern wollen
kein wort von der wirtschaft und den
vorständen und weil ich eben so wie karl
marx und zum gerichts bei den
koalitionsverhandlungen mit dabei war
weiß ich es gab null spielraum in den
koalitionsverhandlungen und drittens
weil unsere ministerin franziska
gefallen und christine lambrecht mit
klarheit der heiligkeit und viel
unterstützung am ball geblieben sind
und eines ist klar ohne spd in dieser
bundesregierung gebe es diese vorstands
quote heute nicht
ach ja und dann höre ich leider viel zu
oft das helfe nur wenigen nur
spitzenmanagerin das ist völlig falsch
und auch quatsch denn wir frauen in
vorständen braucht muss einen
kulturwandel einläuten konkrete frau
förderung auf allen ebenen im
unternehmen
wir machen noch viel mehr das ist schon
zu wort gekommen in dieser debatte und
deshalb dass führungspositionen gesetz 2
ist ein historischer meilenstein
die mindesten wollte in vorständen ist
da und wir als spd werden weitermachen
mit klarheit beharrlichkeit und der
unterstützung aus der gesellschaft ich
freue mich darauf denn unser ziel ist
und muss es sein fifty fifty
das ist nicht nur eine frage der
gerechtigkeit nein das ist auch gut für
unsere unternehmen und die gesamte
deutsche wirtschaft
katja mast sprach von einem historischen
meilenstein
zumindest hat der gesetzentwurf zur
quote in den führungspositionen in der
privatwirtschaft jahrelange diskussionen
gebraucht bis er jetzt im bundestag
heute darüber bestimmt werden kann wie
die kolleginnen und kollegen stay on
board bleibt dabei in führungspositionen
mit familie
das ist der zentrale punkt den wir auch
geändert haben in dem
gesetzgebungsverfahren und wo wir ein
bisschen so hatte ich das gefühl die
beiden ministerinnen auch ein zum jagen
tragen mussten
bohrung ging als worum ging es oder
worum geht es drei punkte möchte ich
hervorheben nadine schön hat es eben
schon angesprochen
erstens einmal vorstellte sind keine
arbeitnehmer und deshalb mussten wir den
mutterschutz auf vorstände erstrecken
das ist der erstgeburt hier gibt es
jetzt einen gesetzlichen anspruch und
der zweite punkt es geht um familie es
geht um die typischen lebenssituationen
in der familie schwangerschaft geburt
pflegebedürftigkeit krankheit für diese
zeiten führen wir einen anspruch ein der
nur noch durch wichtige unternehmens
wurde in den ersten drei monaten in
frage gestellt wird kann ein riesiger
schritt nach vorne und für bis zu zwölf
monate führen wir eine ermessensleistung
ein wo wir sagt werden kann auch da kann
noch etwas gegeben werden für die
portabilität die kompatibilität von
familie und beruf wir gehen ja einen
ganz großen schritt nach vorne und ich
möchte die arena poster die oben auf der
tribüne sitzen die auch ich begrüßen
möchte herzlich danken dafür dass sie
diese initiative öffentlich groß
unterstützt hat denn ich glaube sonst
hätten wir die breite unterstützung des
hauses in diesem punkt nicht gab
herzlichen dank
und natürlich geht auch meinen dank an
die ministerin denn die gesetzes
technische umsetzung auch dieses
ergänzungs punkt es war nicht ganz
einfach alles gute für die zukunft auch
bei dieser gelegenheit dass sie nicht
drei punkte nennen
es ist von vielen praktikern gesagt
worden aus dem bereich der
unternehmensberatung das braucht alles
nicht das kann man vertraglich regeln
aber sie ist natürlich ein unterschied
ob man eine gesetzliche regelung hat von
der man ausgeht und wo man dann sagt wir
modifizieren dass dann von der
gesetzlichen regelung her auch für die
durchaus regelungs notwendigen fälle wo
man sagt man bleibt vielleicht teilweise
dem unternehmen erhalten oder ob man die
regelung erst erkämpfen muss das ist der
erste punkt der zweite punkt wie auch
über die frage nachgedacht braucht man
eine solche regelung auch für
aufsichtsräte
weil wir gesagt nein das braucht man
nichts weil aufsichtsräte typischerweise
nebentätigkeiten sind und der dritte
punkt über den wir nachgedacht haben ist
könnte man nicht eine regelung des ruhms
einführen
und da hatten die gesellschaftsrechtler
aus dem hause und auch mich am ende
überzeugt wir sollten in der systematik
die wir haben drinbleiben widerruf der
bestellung und neubestellung das ist das
liedermacher ist das was wir gemacht
haben ein gutes gesetz und dafür bitte
ich um zustimmung herzlichen dank
niemand hörte war das für die
unionsfraktion und er leitet auch seit
ende 2009 10 den ausschuss für recht und
verbraucherschutz die letzte rednerin in
dieser debatte zur
geschlechtergerechtigkeit kommt
ebenfalls aus der unionsfraktion
erwartet hier schon darauf dass sie
aufgerufen wird säge launert
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen sind damen und
herren wir haben uns ja wirklich bemüht
aber trotz aller anstrengungen konnten
wir leider keinen passenden bewerberin
finden wir würden ja gerne wir frauen in
unsere führungsetage holen aber leider
gibt es nicht ausreichend qualifizierte
bewerberinnen deren profile auf diese
stellen passen
ich glaube das sind sätze die haben
jetzt viel zu oft und viel zu lange
gehört und ich hoffe damit damit endlich
schluss ist die zeit der ausreden ist
vorbei
im auch wenn es immer wieder behauptet
wird
es gibt sie die qualifizierten
motivierten engagierten frauen die gerne
in spitzenpositionen wollen und die da
auch hingehören es gibt sieht man muss
sie nur suchen fördern aufbauen
vor allen dingen gerne aber den ersten
schritt gemacht mit der führungsposition
gesetz 1 und so wie es ist in einem
rechtsstaat es gibt immer den vorrang im
rahmen der verhältnismässigkeit erstes
milderen mittel wenn es geeignet ist zu
wählen haben wir uns darauf eingelassen
und haben den unternehmen vertraut dass
man es freilich hinkriegt wir nehmen
rücksicht auf die unternehmen immer
wieder weil die auf eine
grundrechtspositionen haben aber wir
haben auch den auftrag aus der
verfassung auf die tatsächliche
durchsetzung der gleichberechtigung
hinzuwirken und leider hat dieser frage
weg nicht geklappt und besonders eilig
ist immer wieder dieser hohe anteil an
quote 0 nur männer sagen nun männer sind
immer der qualifiziertere weg wir geben
uns eine quote 0
deutlicher kann es nicht sein dass es
eine gläserne gegeben und besser diese
ermöglichen es ist eine durchbrechung
ihm eine nicht weit genug
der andere zug für den anderen fehlt so
weit ich habe nicht mehr viel zeit ich
habe leider immer als letzte rednerin
der csu sozusagen die die arschkarte
gezogen
ich möchte ich möchte diese ausdrücke
nicht stehen lassen
ich möchte es nicht stehen lassen hier
dass man sagt und unternehmen
verpflichtet untaugliches personal
ich verstehe nicht dass ich nicht machen
auch die frauen unglaublich beleidigt
fühlen von solch einem ausdruck
[Applaus]
die jungs sind nicht mögliches personal
ein weiterer ausdruck die frau als
quoten denn bestimmt in trauer als
quotenfrau abzustellen
die machen ihren job und man den guten
die bewegen sich in ihrem job und wenn
nicht abgestempelt als quotenfrau andere
meinung haben mit der quote das kann man
wenn man die wirtschaft an erster stelle
steht und es nicht um einen ausgleich
zwischen den verschiedenen
verfassungshütern geht aber man soll der
frauen nicht dermaßen abstimmen das fand
ich schrecklich das hat mich echt
zutiefst betroffen
in einer der letzten ganz ganz wichtigen
debatten in diesem hause schön
[Applaus]